cloudy with a chance of meatballs it's
our favorite kids book from growing up
and we knew that Sony had the rights to
the loop to the book so we ambushed them
or like we have to make this movie we
pitch him and take on it which was
basically let's do it kind of like a
Jerry Bruckheimer movie and they like
that that was six years ago and we've
been directing at full time in the last
three years and so basically the story
follows the story of the book was sort
of expands on it and so it's about this
guy Flint Lockwood was a young
adventurer played by Bill Hader and he
makes a machine that makes it rain food
from the sky so at first it's all great
with rating cheeseburgers and there's a
giant jell-o mold they bounce around
like a bounce house and ice cream snow
day but then the food takes a turn for
the worst and then things get really bad
like there's a huge pickle that smashes
and like destroys buildings there's a
pancake that covers up the school and
there's a huge avalanche of like all the
leftovers that rolls through town and
basically like wipes and clean over it
becomes like then they everybody has to
evacuate on these big enormous boats
made out of like old stale bread and
with the pizza slices for sales and
stuff
it proved like 500 people and and a
really long process of trying like
design every inch of the movie every
blade of grass in every last detail all
right the book was our number one
inspiration and we try to put as many of
the moments in the hooker in the movie
we also love limited to D style
animation so we try to figure out a way
to get some of that style into a full 3d
rich environments we took looked at a
lot of like classic limited animation
stuff we looked at we look at the
Muppets who are a really good
inspiration of like something that
exists in three dean is really simple
but appealing we wanted the movie to you
know look there's a lot of these movies
coming out so we wanted ours to look as
unique as it possibly could we wanted it
to the book has a great like tactile
like handmade timer feel so we didn't
want any right angles no parallel lines
we wanted the whole new be to feel like
it was handmade as we put tons of
attention to detail after that well
there is a video game based on the movie
from Ubisoft coming out like two weeks
before the movie comes out and one of
the things that was great about about
design
film was that we were able to build this
entire town and because we were able to
do that we exported all of those digital
assets that we be soft so they have like
this immersive town we could put our
camera anywhere and you can direct your
character and there's a lot of like
crazy stuff from the movie would like a
giant spaghetti tornado that ravaged the
town and I'm going food Avalanche coming
all over the place and even mutant food
that sort of attacks people and so again
I think of weirdest need is probably
watching Andy Samberg climb out of a
chicken carcass and then adopt it as
like a suit and operated kind of like
robotech we also have a crazy cast of
other by comedy hero they're going Bill
Hader and on a ferris Neil Patrick
Harris mr. t Bruce Campbell Bobby J
Thompson and my comedy hero Al Roker
been on Brad and Lauren Graham will
forte as we grew so we had a lot of fun
you